[MUSIC PLAYING]
My father said, I ought
to go to Boston Tech.
And there was a kid
named Tom Peterson
who went east to Harvard.
And when he came over in
the summer, I said Tom,
did you ever hear
of Boston Tech?
Well, he said, no.
They changed the name,
they moved it from Boston
over to Cambridge, and they
called the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
[CHEERING]
And then he looked me right
in the eye and said real loud,
they only take smart ones!
[LAUGHTER]
I learned from that not to ever
believe anything that a Harvard
person tells you.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, it seems like yesterday
I came over here in 1926
to look over MIT.
I had been working
in Schenectady,
New York at the General
Electric company,
and was admitted as
a graduate student
in electrical engineering
to work on motors.
It was during the course
of his graduate studies
in electrical engineering
that Doc designed
and developed the strobe.
He needed a way to observe parts
that moved so quickly that they
were a blur, and it
was for this purpose
that he invented something new--
an incredibly brief,
controllable, and repeatable
flash.
I worked for three
years on motors,
and I suddenly
realized, hey, there's
a lot of things in
the world that move.
And I looked around, there
was a faucet [INAUDIBLE]
right next to where I worked.
So I just moved the strobe
over and took pictures of water
coming out of the faucet.
And that's the first picture I
ever took, except for a motor.
And Edgerton found that
there were other ways
to study motion.
By repeatedly flashing a strobe,
he could create multiple images
on a single photograph.
Now, there exists a
[INAUDIBLE] picture--
whether the lights running
100 times a second,
I got two big powerful
strobe lights.
Well, here comes the club--
see, it's accelerating,
and you can plot a curve
into the velocity
versus time, and you
get the [INAUDIBLE] information
here [INAUDIBLE] the slightest
bit interested in, such is
the velocity of his tee.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, this picture was a fizzle.
I normally throw away
all my bad negatives,
and I was just about
to throw this out,
and I thought, oh, I'll
make a print of that.
And it's down in the Museum
of Modern Art in New York.
[LAUGHTER]
Supposed to be real art.
I don't care-- that's all right,
if they want to call it art,
why don't you call it art.
Well, I [INAUDIBLE] was more
of an electrical engineer,
because it's all done
with electricity.
You saw these [INAUDIBLE]
slides around here--
they're all batteries
and capacitors
and electronic lamps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I know there's somebody come
in here from MGM, and he says,
I want a movie of
throwing a custard pie
through an electric fan.
Well, I said, I'm a
serious scientist.
I'm not going to fool
with any custard pies.
Well, let's compromise on
an egg-- what do you say?
The film was called,
Quicker'n a Wink,
and it won a 1936
Academy Award for MGM.
I always thought that my
cat, in lapping her milk,
curled her tongue up.
But now it's revealed that
she curls her tongue down.
See?
In other words, she
brings the milk up
on the underside of her tongue.
Now, see how smart you get
when you go to the movies?
Years later, Doc
and his colleagues
added the finishing touch,
matching slow-motion sound
to high-speed pictures.
[PHONE RINGING]
[BELLS RINGING]
This was amazing--in the war,
when we were having trouble
with the Germans, and we wanted
to know what they were doing
at night time.
The year was 1938.
Doc and his associates went to
work on the top-secret project.
The end result was
57,000 watt second strobe
package, powered by 8 kilowatts,
and weighing 3,700 pounds.
The value of the aerial
strobe dramatically
demonstrated the night before
the invasion of Normandy.
The photos showed little or
no movement of enemy troops,
indicating that the Germans were
unprepared for the invasion.
The clouds were down
about 1,000 feet,
and the flash bomb
couldn't use it at all,
because they were designed
to be working at 10,000 feet.
So those pictures were useful.
They were used all
during the war.
The Atomic Energy
Commission asked
Edgerton and his associates,
Germeshausen and Greer,
to form a company,
which later became EG&G,
and to design a testing camera
to analyze nuclear explosions.
And then suddenly
one day, we had
an agreement with
the Russians not
to have any more atom bombs.
All my friends came around here
and said oh, that's too bad,
your company is
going down the drain.
Well, that was the
best year we ever had,
because all the people got
up early in the morning
and started thinking
about other things to do.
And there was all
kinds of things to do.
Doc turned his strobe
to the undersea world,
where movement was
sometimes imperceptible.
By having a movie
camera that takes
one picture every
20 seconds, and you
can take things that happen
slowly and speed them up.
Now, I was trying to get these
sand dollars to spell MIT.
[LAUGHTER]
They're very poor learners,
very poor learners.
[LAUGHTER]
I asked him to bring some
of those sand dollars
back, because my grandson
wanted to see them.
Actually, it was me
that wanted to see them,
but that's all right.
They have little
round things-- they've
got small feet on the bottom,
so they can walk around.
Up, Eric, up!
Raise them up!
That a boy.
[LAUGHTER]
I got a telephone call that said
there was some unknown man come
in from France, named
Jacques Cousteau,
and nobody ever heard of him.
But he's here, and could
he come up and talk to you
about underwater photography?
So he came in, and I found out
he had invented the aqua lung.
And he hadn't been at MIT more
than a couple hours before we
had a tank on his
back, and he was
testing my latest underwater
strobe in the swimming pool.
And that led to many, many
expeditions on the Calypso,
and a lot of articles
in the Geographic.
Edgerton found
that sonar could be
used to make
pictures with sound,
just as photographs
are made with light.
At Boston's Charles
River, he developed
and tested a whole new
array of sonar devices.
One called a boomer, or pinger,
penetrates the underwater mud
to reveal objects below.
Another of Edgerton's
sonar inventions
is a side scanner, used to
locate objects which project
above the bottom of the sea.
I was in Athens with
Cousteau on the Calypso,
and he came in one day
and said, is that side
scan sonar is good
for picking up
a ship that's 1,000 feet long?
Think you can find it?
Well, I said, if I
can't, we better go home.
With a sonar, you ought to be
able to find it in no time.
It was a long ways from
where anybody ever thought.
[YELLING]
And there it was, just
as clear and sharp.
Hi, how are you?
When MIT has its
open [INAUDIBLE],,
Dr. Edgerton makes thousands of
copies of his famous milk drop
pictures, and gives
them away to what he
hopes may be future students.
The milk drop is probably
the best known picture
Dr. Edgerton has ever taken.
But he is equally well-known
as a superb teacher.
Now, we'll try to find
it with the strobe.
And this disk is used in
music for tuning instruments.
You swing in a microphone,
it changes the frequency
of the light, you look at a disk
that's run by a constant feed
motor, and you can tell
whether the girl's singing
flat or sharp, or
whatever it is.
Some people can tell
without this strobe.
[LAUGHTER]
If you have a particular
interest in these things,
we got here, come on
down and run them.
[APPLAUSE]
Several years ago, I heard
Jean Brown make a remark
that she hadn't been married
to Gordon very long before she
realized that he
had another love--
MIT.
I, too, had the same experience
when I married Harold.
Unfortunately, it didn't
take me very long to become
enamored with MIT, myself.
And so we've been a happy
triangle ever since.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
One of the first miracles
that happened to me
is when I was about
five years old,
and my father brought home
a beautiful Jersey cow.
And he let it in the
barn, and my sister
and I went in after him,
and we were both given cups
by my mother, and we'd put
them under the faucet--
[LAUGHTER]
--and drink that warm
milk out of that cow.
It was really an
experience to remember.
I also remember there was a
smart aleck kid from Omaha--
that's a big town, you know?
I live in a little town.
And he says, how does it work?
Well, I say, you put hay
and water in one end,
and there's a kind of a bag
on the other with those four
things that's
sticking down there.
And he says, what are those for?
Well, I said, one
of them is for milk,
the other one's for skim
milk, another one's for cream.
He says, what's
the other one for?
I said, that's for
chocolate milk.
You can see, even when
I was five years old,
I was an educator.
Yeah, but you see,
my question is,
even if this goes off in
one millionth of a second,
if your shutter speed
is not that quick,
you're not going see it anyway.
You don't use a
shatter in the camera.
You do it in a
dark room, and you
let all the exposure
come from the light.
There you go, I
didn't realize that.
You learned something tonight.
Congratulations.
[LAUGHTER]
So there's a lot of
things I can't do,
I just say, push that over.
That's for the next generation.
Finally this evening,
our person of the week.
It is unusual for us to
choose someone who just died.
We do so this week because,
as often happens, only
when someone dies does a
really large audience of people
have come to realize
and appreciate
how much that person
had accomplished.
And we are all so much
more enlightened because
of this man's imagination.
Doc Edgerton, the
scientist and teacher,
who wanted to be remembered
as much for his views on life
as much as for the life
he enabled us to view.
And so we choose Harold Doc
Edgerton, who has died at 86.
Tinkerer and visionary,
he shed light
where there was only shadow.
He enlarged the world for
scientists, historians,
and those of us just
with family scrapbooks.
He was, most
personally, dedicated
to those thousands of people who
passed through his classroom.
I'm just a crazy old professor,
he said, crazy like a fox.
[MUSIC PLAYING]